hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown president biden
facing several challenges including
struggling poll numbers inflation and a
stalled agenda with the midterm
elections months away democratic
congressman josh gottheimer of new
jersey breaks down the party's plans and
how a supreme court vacancy could impact
the midterms
co-host of fox and friends and hosts of
the brian kilmeade radio show brian
kilmeade joins the rundown he chats
about the launch of his new weekend show
one nation his fox nation series what
made america great and his push to unite
americans instead of dividing them plus
commentary by comedian chris freed the
fox news rundown is a daily news podcast
where we take a deeper look at the
stories important to you you can
subscribe on your favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm greg gutfeld i'm tammy bruce i'm
steve ducey and this is the fox news
rundown
friday january 28 2022 i'm lisa brady
rising crime is a growing concern for
many americans can a new police reform
bill help the big lesson is
you need to invest not to fund you need
to actually put resources forward to
help our officers our departments and
our communities to make them stronger
i'm dave anthony he's keeping his day
job but brian kilmeade is adding to his
busy schedule with a prime time saturday
night tv show well i just think that
there's a lot of things uh dividing our
country i want to see if i can find some
things that don't
and i'm chris freed i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
an outpouring of support from around the
country has followed the ambush style
killing of two young police officers in
new york city when is it going to stop
when did we become the bad guys it just
doesn't make any sense to me we're out
there risking our lives for the
community tommy shevlin is president of
the police benevolent association in
nassau county new york he says they need
support every day from the community and
elected officials but law enforcement
has been a hotly debated topic in recent
years after the mass protests and riots
that followed the killing of george
floyd in minneapolis helping to fuel the
defund police movement
now we're in a midterm election year
which could make it more difficult to
get anything done in congress i'm
optimistic you know i i think if you
look at what we were able to come
together around at the end of last year
on the bipartisan infrastructure bill
which i worked quite a bit on democratic
congressman josh gottheimer is in his
third term serving new jersey's fifth
district he also co-chairs the house
problem solvers caucus 29 democrats and
29 republicans our roads bridges
uh rail water infrastructure we all sat
together you know i co-chair this group
called the problem solvers caucus which
is 29 democrats and 29 republicans we
come together every week with one
purpose of getting things done and i
think now with the
piece of legislation focused on china on
ships manufacturing more domestic
manufacturing especially we see out of
covid and how reliant we were on on
foreign manufacturing and how we need to
do more of it here at home that
legislation is bipartisan as well you
know and then you've got legislation
that we're talking about today which the
investor protect act which is also
bipartisan so i'm confident that if we
actually sit together and work together
and whether you're dealing with
affordability issues or
our foreign affairs issues we there's
plenty we can do across the aisle to get
done
so the invest protect act
is basically a police reform bill
correct what what's in it and is it you
know different or similar to other
proposals in recent years
there's been several efforts that i've
been involved with on police reform over
the last couple years working with
democrats and republicans together with
the problem solvers caucus and this
takes parts of it out of some of our
work and and places where we've been
able to find common ground it's why uh
congressman rutherford who's a
republican from florida former sheriff
and i wrote the bill we've got about 40
co-sponsors now half democrat half
republican it's backed by the fop and
the turn order police and the sheriff
association and and napo and
it focuses on on four key areas where
you know really needs we need to invest
especially in our smaller departments
with 200 or fewer officers where there's
tends to be fewer resources one it
invests in training safety de-escalation
domestic violence response training that
helps our smaller departments pay for
overtime where you know in my district
we've got 79 towns most of whom have
their own police departments so you need
they have smaller departments they need
help to be able to take people off out
of their police cars and make sure they
get the training they need uh so that's
that's one two
it supports body-worn cameras uh to hold
everyone accountable especially on the
storage side of it which tends to be
very expensive every year and a lot of
our departments just can't afford that
three it gives resources to recruit new
officers and to retain current officers
make sure we keep the best make our
department stronger right now as you
know given all that's gone on it's
harder to recruit and retain officers
and the fourth big area is resources for
mental health for our uh uh resources
for our officers and this came about by
talking to departments by talking to
communities and we pulled this together
and there's a ton of support for it and
i think the big lesson is
you need to invest not to fund you need
to actually put resources forward to
help our officers our departments and
our communities to make them stronger
a couple of things on that
first
you know how do you pitch
more funding for police to americans who
maybe thought that defunding quote
unquote was the answer
that's a great question i mean i think
if we've learned anything from the last
couple years is that to have stronger
departments
and better officers you're not going to
get there by cutting budgets to the bone
you end up then actually making weaker
departments because you need to invest
in training and if you want good
training you actually de-escalation
training or domestic violence training
you have to put resources behind that
i think officers and communities agree
about body worn cameras
but they cost money
right and you need to actually
invest to keep the best law enforcement
on the job so
and you got to support mental health i
mean these are all things we've learned
even more through these years and you
know i think
the new mayor of new york city eric
adams who was a former police captain
himself said
he said i don't just subscribe to the
belief of some that we can only have
justice and not public safety we can
have them both
and that's my view right you can do both
but the idea of cutting departments and
cutting investment and expecting better
outcomes
makes no sense to me and that's the kind
of conversations i've had with my
colleagues about this
were there things that you wanted to put
in and left out in the hopes that it
could gather more support than previous
bills and you know does this bill stand
a better chance of getting all the way
to the president's desk
well there are so there's oh there are
other areas we worked on that we didn't
get to agreement on
uh and so when we put this bill together
we wanted to actually say instead of
letting the perfect be the enemy the
good
what do we think is that what's the best
set of policies that we can draw by part
of support and get to the president's
desk
and that's how we developed the focus on
the areas of policy that we did
and this is just it's not the be all
end-all but it's a really really
important step and we'll keep working
and i think you know the folks who think
it's 100 or nothing are wrong you know
if you just wait till everything's
perfect before you actually move forward
you'll never get anything done so
that's that's been really our approach
here and and again i think that one of
the big takeaways is that randomly
cutting budgets
does not lead to safer communities you
really have to invest in mental health
and transparency and safety and training
and make sure our officers who put their
lives on the line every day and you know
we sadly tragically lost two officers in
the last week in the line of duty in new
york city you realize we got to get
their backs we got to do right by them
and and that's what this legislation is
about doing right by them and doing
right by the communities they protect
one other thing along these lines i mean
would you envision this as being sort of
in addition to
other
efforts to help fight
you know rising crime rates
yes i think listen again this doesn't
have everything it's
but and there's more to do
and i think we must do more mayor adams
in new york city just like many of our
mayors here in new jersey have taken
steps on community policing and to fight
crime and get guns off the streets this
is a very concrete important bipartisan
step
and i think we've got to act
acting on legislation has been more
complicated in the 50-50 senate though
president biden now has a chance to
bring his party together with a supreme
court nominee someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court the president reaffirming
a campaign pledge as he thanked justice
stephen breyer for his service the
court's oldest justice at 83 confirming
his upcoming retirement during a white
house meeting on thursday of course
people don't agree
but we have a country
that is based on
human rights democracy and so forth but
i'll tell you what lincoln thought what
washington thought and what people today
still think it's an experiment breyer
will serve out the current term
president biden plans to have a nominee
by the end of next month well obviously
that's a very important responsibility
of any president and democrat or
republican so i think it's it's a very
important pick i think he will be able
to unite the party and move forward with
with who he nominates and obviously
we're just the beginning of this process
you know they uh i'm in the house so
they don't ask our opinion on this in
the senate but um you know i'm i believe
that you know the process just beginning
of course but i think that's going to be
an important responsibility of the
senate in the next months but we have so
much else to do right on on the
affordability side and i've got an
affordability agenda we're fighting to
cut taxes and reinstate salt and get
health care costs down and help with
child care costs get people to work
there's a lot on our plate and i think
we have to do all of it
yeah along the lines of affordability
and the cost issues
i know that one of your fellow democrats
congresswoman alyssa slotkin recently
suggested that the biden white house
isn't showing enough of a sense of
urgency on inflation of cost of living
she says that's what she hears about
when when she sits down with people i
know the president tries to make the
case build back better is part of the
inflation solution
are you concerned about that not
resonating with people
well i'll tell you what i hear at home
you know our people people are concerned
when they have to cost the grocery store
and the gas stations and i think we need
to tackle it you know i've i've been
aggressive in the legislation i've
introduced dealing with supply chain
issues and shipping issues the effects
of the covet economy right the fact that
there's you know boxes piled up outside
everyone's home during covid it's put a
lot of strain on the supply chain as you
know uh internationally and got ports
around the world closed so i've got the
legislation dealing with that we've
passed more domestic manufacturing
investment legislation which i think
will help so there's a lot we can and
have to do but it it really takes
democrats and republicans working
together and uh we in the problem
solvers caucus we've been working on
these issues and working on legislation
together because
this is our responsibility and so
that means it's the white house but it
means that it's democrats and
republicans in the house the senate and
we're all working together to address
these issues we're still in the covet
economy here in the throes of the
covenant economy and it's up to us all
as a country to respond
one last question for you
what do you say to fellow democrats who
are
worried about the midterms or to
republicans who are trying to make the
case that they should get back control
well i would say to any democrat or
republican who's an elected official we
ought to do our jobs and and put country
ahead of party and make sure that you
pay attention whether um listen i'm
focused on fixing roads and bridges and
potholes about to actually go to a
bridge now that we're fighting for
resources it's more than a century old
and we're dealing with a tunnel between
new york and new jersey called the
gateway train tunnel to get that fixed
and a new tunnel built you know you got
to help veterans
who we love and are so grateful for and
our first responders and get their backs
and you know and look out for people
that's that's what people when voters go
to the booth they ultimately are going
to grade you on are you fighting for
them regardless of their party and
that's our responsibility and so that's
what i say to my colleagues and if you
just do the right thing and fight for
the people you represent and get the job
done and and leave the politics
second to to doing your job
what do you what do you say to the
voters
who are maybe wondering you know have
the democrats done enough
to
be able to keep going
i'm just in a diner this morning i'm
from jersey right we go to diners best
diners in america and two folks came up
to me and said we talked about salt and
reinstating salt and they talked about
how they really appreciate what i was
doing on the gateway tunnel and fighting
for
bipartisan governing to get things done
and what we got done on it on that
infrastructure bill which was once in a
century that matters to them that's
those are the potholes that's their
commute that's uh seeing their kids at
night getting to work in the morning you
know and they want to know that their
member of congress is working with
everybody democrat and republican to get
things done for them they expect us to
actually work together and not point
fingers you know and i i just focus on
my district i don't work for a national
political party i work for for the
people in the fifth district in jersey
and that's what i'm focused on
new jersey democratic congressman josh
gottheimer thank you so much for your
time great talking to you
[Music]
this is chris fried with your fox news
commentary coming up
what made america great
a lot of things and for years brian
kilmeade's been detailing them in a fox
nation series now into season eight with
two new episodes the first is a feature
on ellis island this was the path that
was paved with gold in people's minds
and their vision and it was what our
founding parents and documents
envisioned that a new generation would
sojourn through this not knowing where
they were going to go and for most of
those millions of people 98 of them that
came through here they were accepted and
sent on into america to hopefully find
work and brian is going to tell you a
lot more but not quite yet
first the fox and friends co-host has a
new tv show well i just think that
there's a lot of things dividing our
country i want to see if i can find some
things that don't brian kilmeade's one
nation debuts this saturday night on fox
news channel at 8 p.m eastern joe
manchin looks at these democrats yelling
at him and said i don't know if you guys
met me before but i've always been a
moderate center left i don't know if you
know the country but we're center-right
and the press was just befuddled like
why would you stop this left-wing agenda
and it just brought to my mind the
thought that we have lost sempelin's
semblance of order and we're all my team
your team and i think we got to get on
one team doesn't mean i'm not going to
bring up issues that divide but i'm
going to try to make it in a fun
informative way rather than an
aggressive abusive way
now that's the spot that jesse waters
used to do that show now he's moved to
weekdays at 7 pm eastern time
has he given you any tips has he left
any shirts with the collars up for you
to wear what's happening no jesse uh it
doesn't talk to me now because he's
prime time during the week same thing
with shawn and tucker i cannot get them
on the phone they don't return a text
laura once in a while if she needs
change of a dollar she might just ask me
for something but when you go prime time
there's no reason to talk to a morning
guy let alone a radio guy let alone on
top of that a weekend guy
are you going to be lonely i mean you're
not going to have
ainsley steve won't be there you can't
toss to the weather for janus nothing
like that right that'll be fun actually
that's what i do very similar on the
brian kilmeade radio show and just to be
able to say okay i got eight minutes in
this block and i can control what
happens to a degree but i do want to
give a sense that this whole thing is
not scripted i do want to have some
familiar faces on but some unfamiliar
faces too
so i really want to make sure the the uh
eight o'clock show as different as
tucker's is during the week i mean you
never know where tucker's going at eight
with his monologue and i hope that
people look at the show at eight one
nation and say man i don't i know
roughly what to expect but man i don't
know
how this show's gonna go because i want
people to feel
that there's an unscripted nature to it
almost like stuff that we live every day
in radio yeah you know whatever and then
radio is such a a different
and unique and fun thing to do i mean
this is the thing that a lot of other
hosts on fox tv don't get to do what you
get to do and that is talk to people
directly as much as you get to
i love that you said that because the
way you build relationships they say you
network and in this environment you
can't really network like you used to
there's no water cooler to hang out with
six feet apart i'm working remote but
the one thing about radio that allowed
me to build up my network of contacts
and friends
is the nature of the medium so you know
if i have newt gingrich for four minutes
on tv i know the three topics going to
talk about i'm going to say hello i'm
going to say goodbye sure but if i have
him for 12 minutes he's got a book and i
can actually say what's the book about
without blowing the break
yeah and be able to say hey by the way
this just came across nancy pelosi is
going to go for a 19th term
let's change gears they have the control
room's not in my ear saying wait a
second we have no banners you know we
have no sound what are you doing yeah so
it is just as that that freedom that we
enjoy and then at the end of 12 minutes
you're a lot closer to that person
understand them more and they want to
come back again because man in that 12
minutes i really had a chance to talk
right because so most of some of the
smartest people you're ever going to
meet are on the radio show and in my
case would never talk to me if i didn't
have it so when i give them their
opportunity to talk around the country
to millions of people hopefully
listeners they appreciate it kind of
builds a relationship and newt gingrich
he's a talker you might even go and say
hey hold on let's have you in another
segment right the only thing he lost me
on is colonizing the moon if he was
president when he said that in the
debate i thought oh i think he just lost
yeah yeah well at least it wasn't mars i
mean that
moon's at least closer well yeah mars
takes three and a half years i think
yeah yeah that's not not likely almost
over by the time you arrive you gotta
get reelected to get it back home
what made america great your fox nation
series you've been working on this for a
while and season eight the first couple
of episodes have dropped now on fox
nation
the first one ellis island so you got to
go there how great is that yeah i mean
this is where 12 million people minimum
came through where 40 percent of the
country traced their roots back to
and you have a chance to
see the [ __ ] the would have been a steam
ship back then pull up exactly where the
docks are we get off and i get off with
a historian and an immigration attorney
whose family may be the most famous
successful in the country whose family
goes back to ellis island so i got the
expert on one side and i got the
historian on the other and we take the
journey that 12 million took and we go
in the same door we weighed on the same
line where physicians would run up to
you and try to find if there's anything
transparently wrong with you and
families and how they come together and
see what they look like and they're
getting their presentation in and we
take the journey as you walk up the big
platform and then you work your way to
where you're inspected and if you do
fail and your story isn't good and where
the america or the inspector says i'm
not sure you're going to be able to help
us why don't you go to court there's
courtrooms that are still there and
refurbished places where you had to
sleep if you weren't feeling well they
wouldn't throw you out right away they
said i'm going to give you a couple of
days to get better and there's different
barracks and there's pictures of these
people and it's the immigration the
american experiment experience done the
right way as opposed to sneaking
serpentine style through the border
hoping bill mollusion doesn't put you on
camera yeah going across a river and
taking your family or or being smuggled
or all those things now when you go
through that and you're going up the
actual steps right that people did like
a hundred plus years ago yeah the same
steps they made sure to restore them and
put them back it was my first time there
so my first time i'm actually on camera
with a 40-minute documentary on it and i
just think it'll wet people's appetite
to find out what really happened one
myth i'd like to burst right now yeah
for the longest time they would say well
if your name was too complicated at
ellis island they would change it and
you couldn't have a say in it they never
changed the single name at ellis island
that was done when you got assured
uh when you went for immigration your
final immigration papers or when you
registered to have a job or as a citizen
officially okay so it wasn't done right
there it wasn't there it was someone
else and a different processing yeah
that that did that change last names and
all these kinds of things
um when you
when you think about ellis island i mean
it is a symbol i mean the statue of
liberty is right there
yeah i mean just think about this moment
for some reason you're leaving whatever
reason it is it's usually not leaving a
good situation or you're joining your
family or you're the first in your
family and you've got to forge this this
you want to go to the new world to forge
a new identity and with new hope and
opportunity but there's no social safety
net and can you imagine coming into new
york harbor you look up and there's the
statue of liberty and over to the right
is the island in which you hope to
impress the inspectors enough where you
become an american citizen you don't
have to tell that person to stand during
the national anthem you don't have to
tell that person to put their hand over
their heart and sing loud or take the
pledge of allegiance they did when they
got on the ship so they were there to
perform and they were flat out honest
what could you do what are your skills
who will house you are you going to be a
ward of the state because we don't have
money to support a bunch of people who
can't feed their family the other new
episode of what made america great on
fox nation focuses on teddy roosevelt he
was a
fierce fighter of corruption big
business he took them on
he took out a lot of a lot of people but
we're not talking about his time as
president before roosevelt was in the
white house he took charge of new york
city policing it was a major change and
he was really
the first reformer
and the police badly needed it former
new york police commissioner ray kelly
joins brian on yet another of
roosevelt's accomplishments
i mean his environmentalist he was a a
governor uh he was a war hero
and he started off in a way in his
childhood he was so sickly many people
didn't think he could survive he
couldn't even go to formal schooling his
asthma was so bad uh they had to keep an
eye on him they didn't really feel they
can put him in an environment where he
could possibly get sick so by the time
he gets uh becomes in a man and able to
shake most of the effects of the asthma
he overcompensates in my humble opinion
and becomes the most aggressive uh uh
venturing person you could possibly
imagine so one of the things you wanted
to do is okay i helped mckinley get
elected i helped brother b hayes get
elected so let me uh let me see if i can
help out with civil service and when he
started helping out civil services yeah
put me in new york i wanted to see if i
could uh be a head of police and before
there was an official police
commissioner teddy roosevelt took over
basically a committee and he found out
all the cops were irish they basically
were a lot of them were corrupt there
was no organization no academy no
streamlining of guns they had no sense
of shifts and accountability he put all
that in place and to do it he had to
really shake this institution from the
core and what he did is enlist the press
to help him and one of the first areas
he hit is five points in new york and
the box still exists the way it was
these immigrants were really put up by
slumlords they live in the most horrific
conditions you could possibly imagine
but new immigrants had so little rights
and no political power so they for the
most part were abused so what he did is
brought a photographer with him and he
literally put flash photography that
would light up a dark room and would
show these families and what they were
going through and then he would put it
on the paper and then he would walk
around and make the cops crack down on
these guys and then when it came down to
actually fixing the neighborhood he said
we're not going to fix it by building
new buildings we're going to wreck them
and make a park we're going to make this
a place that families can enjoy you know
that park is still there and then you
see what he did for the police force in
particular ray kelly brings me through
he said i used his desk we all use his
desk bratton used his desk because what
he did for the city we truly appreciate
it he gave them a sense of pride of
being in law enforcement and he let
other people like italians and jewish
people uh become cops can you imagine uh
and and just broadened it out and made
him accountable and made the modern
police force that's what he did in two
and a half years
and and this is all before he became a
war hero it's before
1898 and it's before of course he became
vice president and president
but in
2021 22 the modern era his statute is
gone
and it's uh it's actually in the piece
because i go to the museum of natural
history where ray kelly grew up and we
walked the streets where he was and the
reason there is a museum in natural
history is because to teddy roosevelt a
lot of what he did in hunted is in the
museum of natural history his statue on
a horse with an african-american an
indian next to him because he's on a
horse they said it's not a good image
we're going to get rid of it so they
sent it to the teddy roosevelt museum in
north dakota and it's just criminal
that's just part of the idiocy uh in
america today oh he was he was talking
in a way he had a a mom
that had
relatives fight for the confederacy so
you know he would say some things that
you probably want back that has nothing
to do with the statue he also hooked up
with booker t washington and did more
for race relations and fought for more
uh blacks in america at a time in which
there was such racial division in a way
we never saw a leader do he was the
first man to invite a black man to
dinner with his family at the white
house and it's just he broke barrier
after barrier all right the show is one
nation it's on saturday nights on fox 8
p.m eastern time what made america great
is now something you can get on fox
nation with these specials that brian's
put together the new episodes that are
out and of course you can see my fox and
friends hear him on the radio on the
brian kilmade show brian great to talk
to you thank you very much thank you
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind so the conference
championships are this weekend and uh we
got bengals chiefs we got niners rams i
gotta say i i do want the bengals to win
the whole thing in the super bowl but i
i also have to admit i go mainly by
colors of the team and if i like the
mascot or the helmets in particular i
think if the helmets are cool they have
a better chance
but unfortunately
the news has affected football somewhat
like my dad is more political and he got
really into the whole controversies and
all that so he's you know he goes i know
for the super bowl we're not watching
the super bowl anymore we're we're going
to watch the puppy bowl instead and but
you know it's
sounds like a cute idea and then the lab
sits for the anthem ruins his day
i love those fathers by the way who you
know in football they they've been
making from the stands the same joke for
decades and decades they go hey ref
you're missing a good game never never
been funny once and the people still do
it and love it someday the ref should
just it'd be hilarious if they just
cared one time and gave them a shot you
know and they can and they go
ruling on the field stands as a fumble
however it is being further challenged
by the fat drunken father of the left
tackle who has thrown his challenge boot
on the field i also feel like politics
could benefit from football and you know
it's basically all those congressional
hearings and things that it's all for
show and they're basically team sport
politics like it'd be funny if we start
the hearing and we do the starting
lineups for both teams they're i got a
red and blue jerseys cory booker
yale university
anyway i think it'd make it more
interesting
i'm chris freed my new comedy album it
takes a privilege comes out february
25th but you can pre-order it on itunes
and amazon and anywhere you wish go
bengals
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox nation presents podcasts women of
the bible speak i'm shannon breem host
of fox news at night and author of the
new book women of the bible speak the
wisdom of 16 women and their lessons for
today subscribe now on apple podcast
spotify
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download your podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes